so you just start a keto and your cholesterol
is off the charts what do you do okay there's
a couple important things you need to know number
one and this was in 2018 the new guidelines about
the american heart association okay this
is brand new they said total cholesterol
is not significantly associated with heart disease
okay that's the new finding they just found out
looking at your total cholesterol doesn't
really give you a lot of information with
in relationship to predicting heart disease okay
that's number one number two your body makes 75
25 comes from diet why do we need
cholesterol why does your body make it
to make hormones sex hormones cell
membranes bile to help you digest fat
and vitamin d which is very very crucial
and this is why when people take cholesterol
drugs that block cholesterol as in statins
they have a lot of side effects relating to
these right here which we're not going to
get into now what i did is i took my wife
karen's report okay that i'm going to show you
i'm going to walk you through this this is an
actual report done 11 15 2019 and we checked the
total cholesterol the ldl the hdl triglycerides
and we checked several other things because i
always recommend when you get a cholesterol test
you get an advanced lipid profile an advanced test
that measures the two different types of ldl okay
which we're going to cover now check this out this
is what we found her total cholesterol was 261.
normal is below 200. so this is too high right
so immediately you're probably going to freak out
unless you understand that this total cholesterol
is not the cholesterol that's floating
through your arteries it can't it doesn't
mix well with blood it has to be packaged
in a protein so the total cholesterol is
really all these other things combined okay
so we have ldl which is low density
lipo proteins because you need a protein
kind of a sac to push it through the blood
and we have high density lipo protein okay
so really you know take the cholesterol and just
put it to the side right now all right so we know
the cholesterol is high we also know her ldl look
at that should be below 100 it's 195. it's more
than double where it should be hdl should be
greater than 50 because you want that higher
because that's the cholesterol coming from the
cells back onto the liver okay it's not the ldl
from the liver to the cells it's coming back the
other way hers was really good 71. triglycerides
less than 100 hers were 66. so this is where
it's coming from right here but thank goodness
we did a test that goes a little bit deeper and we
measured two types of ldl one is the large buoyant
type of ldl which is kind of large and fluffy
as it goes through the artery and number two we
measured the small dense ldl particles okay so i
want to focus on this one right here small dense
so the way it's worded on the cholesterol
test is this right here s d l d l dash c
standing for small density all right here
we go here's karen's report we have her name
we have the date and we have the total cholesterol
which is 261 right check that out right there
and the second one this high ldlc that stands for
ldl cholesterol it's 195. okay if we take a look
on the second page right here look at this the ldl
is 2128 right but let's narrow in on this one type
of ldl sd ldl dash c that's the small dense low
density lipoprotein this is one that's dangerous
and it's actually 26 within the normal range
it's optimal so guess what this means it means
that karen's high level of ldl is not the small
dense type it is the large buoyant type and it's
the small dense type that creates the damage
it's one of the better markers for predicting
heart problems it's one of the best indicators for
detecting inflammation deep inside of the arteries
all right so let me just explain the inside of the
arteries so i got this really good analogy from a
dr sanjay gupta on one of his youtube videos using
a frying pan right so it's a really great example
of what happens on the inside of your arteries so
here we have this non-stick frying pan okay so you
fry something on here you put some fat on there
and it doesn't stick right and you rub it or you
scratch this and you get rid of this layer the
fat will start to stick here's what you need to
know cholesterol is not going to affect the inside
of the arteries unless there's first some type of
lesion some type of erosion on the inside of the
arteries where the small dense type ldl can then
penetrate because they're small and start
developing plaquing so the question is why
did karen have such high cholesterol and
such high ldl and also why did she have
more of the large buoyant type versus the small
dense type and that's simply because of this this
comes from a high carb diet it comes from
consuming the wrong types of foods when you're
doing a healthy version of keto where you're doing
higher fats lower carb moderate protein guess what
you're going to get into ketosis you're going to
start burning fat and a fat cell is composed of
mostly triglycerides and cholesterol so that
cholesterol has to come out it has to be mobilized
so you can have certain times or transitional
periods where your cholesterol goes up and it goes
down but as long as you keep your carbs low you're
going to get more of this type of cholesterol
and this is why i always recommend doing an
advanced lipid profile not just your regular
test that doesn't tell you very much information
and so getting back to the arteries there's
various things that cause inflammation
in addition to the glucose in the sugar
which is a kind of a most people know that seed
oils a lot of corn oils canola soy cottonseed
oil and so many different foods mayonnaise salad
dressings going off to dinner eating fried foods
very inflammatory smoking creates inflammation
junk food creates inflammation and also
when you're deficient in vitamin e and you become
deficient in vitamin e when you start consuming
refined flour products and that would be in the
form of breads and pastas cereal crackers biscuits
things like that you start becoming depleted of
vitamin e which is the protective antioxidant to
protect the inside of the arteries and by the
way if you have any problems with the inside
of your artery the best vitamin e to take is not
tocopherols it's tocatrinals okay that's the one
that you would want to help protect the inside
of that layer so now let's take a look inside
the artery and get a visual of what can happen so
we're looking here at the inside of an artery this
tiny layer on the inside of the artery is called
the endothelium and this layer controls the tone
of your blood vessel it can increase the blood
pressure it can decrease the blood pressure
it can make the artery thicker or more
elastic but it's very sensitive to sugar
especially chronic sugar i'm
talking about chronic glucose
an average person in america consumes between 250
to 350 grams of glucose that is at least 13 to 15
times what is normal so when you expose the inside
of your artery to that much glucose what's going
to happen we're going to get this oxidation effect
it's like rusting out the inside of your arteries
now what happens next is the body's response to an
injury we're going to get inflammation we're going
to get calcium that's going to come in there
and start building up and start to to act as a
band-aid we're also going to get cholesterol that
actually mixes in there and acts as a band-aid
we're also going to get fibrous tissue that's
going to act as a band-aid altogether this
band-aid that's created from calcium protein
and cholesterol is going to start to form a clot
and as that artery becomes more obstructed
the blood flow backs up and you start getting
a diminished flow of blood so what does blood
do it carries oxygen and nutrition so now we
not only starve off oxygen to the tissues we
starve off nutrition and if that blood vessel
turns into a capillary and ends up in the bottom
of your feet you'll get peripheral neuropathy
numbness burning tingling if that artery is
the coronary artery that goes to your heart
your heart muscle will start to cramp as an angina
and eventually a heart attack if that clot breaks
off goes up to your brain and starts shutting
off oxygen into your brain you get a stroke and
so all of this can be completely prevented
just by getting the sugar out of the diet
hey before you go real quick i have
a course entitled how to bulletproof
your immune system it's a free course
i want you to take it and here's why
here's you here is your environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here what about
strengthening your immune system that's what's
missing this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself and so you can tolerate
and resist your environment much better by
strengthening your own immune system i put
a link down in the description right down
below check it out and get signed up today